welcome back to tcsn we have a really
special offer for you it's a turkey
cheddar sandwich wow look at that this
is handmade with avocado tomato and
lettuce on an artisanal whole wheat
baguette and it can be yours for only
four easy installments of 2.99 that is a
great deal now I don't know about you
but I like my sandwiches with chips and
a drink we've got you covered look at
this a bag of salt and vinegar potato
chips for three payments of 89 cents and
a Diet Dr dinky Cola for only six
payments of 49 cents I'm sold and hungry
how do I sign up just send us your name
phone number date of birth and social
security number and you can get approved
in seconds so easy
paying for a sandwich in installments
may seem absurd to some but the practice
is becoming more and more popular
especially among younger Shoppers buy
now pay later loans are one of the
hottest new trends in the world
Financial technology touted as a less
risky alternative to credit cards using
one of several major apps you're only
asked for a fraction of the price at the
point of sale and the rest is paid off
in a few bi-weekly installments as long
as you pay on time there's no interest
no interest
oh hold on turbo might sound like a
no-brainer but any Savvy spender knows
you don't dive head first into a new
Financial tool without digging a little
deeper how do bnpl loans really work
what are the drawbacks and dangers and
what's in it for the companies that
offer them
[Music]
times were tough during the Great
Depression and people weren't spending
like they used to so Merchants came up
with a new system called a layaway plan
which allowed Shoppers to put a deposit
down on a purchase and pay the rest off
in installments when the balance is
fully paid off the merchandise is
delivered
layaway plans were popular up until the
1980s when credit cards replaced them as
the preferred way to buy things with
money you don't have but over the last
four decades many Americans have soured
on credit cards associating them with
high interest payments and lifelong debt
spirals so it's no wonder that young
people are starting to embrace buy now
pay later loans as a kind of modern tech
reboot of the layaway plan like layaway
plans they have a no interest
installment structure but like credit
cards you receive the purchase
immediately you don't have to wait until
the balance is paid off if you think
this sounds like a good deal you're not
alone between 2019 and 2021 the total
value of vnpo loans from the major
lenders grew more than a thousand
percent from around 2 billion to over 24
billion the value of transactions
financed this way quadrupled globally
hitting over 120 million more than 40
percent of Americans have used bmpl
loans and there is especially popular
with younger people who make up about
half the user base and they seem to like
it according to Consumer Reports most
users report being satisfied with the
service and a survey by associate
marketing Professor Anastasia gauche
found that unlike credit cards consumers
felt virtually no guilt about using bnpl
loans
this is the part where we say however
isn't it yes it is however there are
drawbacks to bnpl loans that consumer
rights Advocates are trying to sound the
alarm on these are extremely new
Financial inventions which means they're
largely unregulated the truth in Lending
Act which protects you from unfair or
inaccurate credit practices doesn't
apply to buy now pay later they don't
have the rewards programs or protections
of credit cards which means you might
not be able to get a refund if your
purchase is lost or damaged in transit
and just because there's no interest
doesn't mean there aren't penalties for
late payments delinquency rates for bnpl
loans have been steadily growing over
the last few years as have loans charged
off as bad debt when this happens your
credit rating takes a hit but the
reverse is not true most bnpl companies
don't report on-time payments to the
credit bureaus which means they're not a
viable way to build your credit history
also one of bnpl's most attractive
features it's ease of use is also a
hazard people are increasingly using
them for everyday purchases like
groceries utility bills and yes
sandwiches this can lead to Lone
stacking where borrowers quickly lose
track of multiple loans people who use
bnpl loans have seen a dramatic uptick
in overdraft fees and because many have
their bnpl accounts tied to their credit
cards they end up paying interest anyway
but to understand the true danger of
bnpl loans we need to look at the
business strategy of the companies that
offer them these apps market themselves
as friendly cool almost altruistic
organizations just try and help you live
your best life bro but we Savvy Shoppers
know that no Corporation does anything
unless there's something in it for them
which begs the question how does a
lender that doesn't charge interest make
money the answer is Merchant fees
retailers pay bnpl companies to finance
their customer loans and the fees are
three to four times higher than those
from credit card companies which begs
another question why are Merchants
willing to pay such exorbitant prices
because bnpl companies are really really
good at getting customers to spend more
money if you're surfing an online
clothing store with a hundred bucks to
spend you might see a cute top that
usually goes for 80 bucks but you can
have it right now for a deposit of just
twenty dollars throw in a shawla ha pair
of boots and your 100 has financed a
whole new outfit with about three
hundred dollars in installments to pay
off a recent economic study found that
using bnpl loans increases one spending
habit by sixty dollars a week bloating
the average Americans retail budget by
about 30 percent meanwhile they're
tracking your purchases and collecting
your data to develop more effective ways
to get you to spend more as the Director
of the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau put it these firms aren't just
lenders they are also advertisers and
virtual Mall operators we have a
tendency to become entranced by new tech
and think that apps with upbeat names
and hip marketing are really changing
the game for the better but as we've
seen before some tech companies are not
so much disrupting the industry as just
muscling their way into it that's why
some economists think that this buy now
pay later fad is just another loop in
America's Eternal credit cycle it may
seem like the shiny new thing but it
will quickly lose its luster if
consumers keep overspending themselves
into debt and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron want to know more about how the
internet nudges you to overspend check
out our video how social media keeps you
poor